[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: Today we're
going to dive into a topic that
is relevant to all of us right
now, is the coronavirus crisis.
And for those watching in
the future these recordings,
we'll see how many of these
predictions might come true.
But we're going to
try to sort of frame
fintech in this crisis.
And it's both a health care
crisis and an economic crisis.
I thought that I would
spend a little bit of time
in this class talking about some
financial crises in the past.
I'll talk about the 2008
crisis more specifically.
We'll take a look at some
of the economic forecasts
here in May of 2020.
And of course those
looking in the future
will sort of look back and
say, aha, was it better
or was it worse?
I have some points
of view about that,
and I'll share those openly.
And then we'll sort
of finalize about what
this means for fintech and some
of the sectors and subsectors
within the space.
So with that, I am going
to try to share some slides
and get going.
So that's the overview of
what we're going to try to do.
And looking a little bit
at crises, the '08 crisis,
as I said, grounded in
what's happening today.
I'm glad to take questions
at any point in time.
This is a little bit
more relevant today,
but it's also much
broader than just fintech.
Some of the readings
were around what's
happening in financial
technology, the interviews
that TechCrunch put out
of eight top fintech VCs
and what they were saying.
I will also close this
discussion with something
that Boston Consulting Group
just put out in May of 2020.
So just a few
questions to get going
and see if Romain has a little
fun with calling on folks.
But how's the coronavirus
crisis affecting
the financial services
world more broadly?
Not fintech, but the financial
services world more broadly.
And though it wasn't in
the readings, many of you
are studying finance and are
from the world of finance.
So these could be just your
personal opinions, of course.
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Good morning, everyone.
Come on, this is one of your
last opportunities to shine.
Olivia, you have the floor.
AUDIENCE: So with
the stock market
sort of tanking in
the past few months,
that would impact any business
that manages financial assets.
So mutual funds,
hedge funds, the like,
the vast majority
of them probably
have their asset base
declining in a similar way.
They're all working
remote as well.
So you could think of
ways that might impact
other financial services
companies that maybe are not
quite as technologically
savvy as other sectors.
But basically any business--
it could be insurance.
It could be banking--
will have to revalue
the assets that they
hold on their balance sheets.
GARY GENSLER: So can I
pause just for a second
because you mentioned
about four or five
really important things.
One is the volatility and
that financial services really
stands, in our economies,
as managing and helping
the economy more
broadly manage risk.
Taking in risk and transferring
that risk and pricing risk.
But the volatility
itself has come along.
Now, some firms will fail.
Some firms won't.
When I was at Goldman
Sachs, there was a saying--
I didn't create the saying-- is
that volatility was our friend.
Well, it was our friend if
we could manage it well, not
if we stumbled along the way.
But financial firms are
often in the business
of managing risk, whether
they're insurance companies,
investment banks, and the like.
So that's one thing that
Olivia has mentioned.
But she's also mentioned assets.
And in two different ways,
I just want to highlight.
Assets under management for
the wealth management or asset
management field
has shrunk a bit.
And so to the extent
that BlackRock
used to be maybe $7
trillion of assets
and maybe it's $6 trillion
or $6 going to $5,
that's fewer assets
under management.
But also I think
the second piece
that Olivia mentioned is
really critical, is valuing
those assets,
particularly, let's say
you were in a commercial
banking field,
or you were in a fintech
field making loans.
The actual loan side
of the balance sheet,
you're seeing that commercial
bank after commercial bank
is taking losses on those
loans in anticipation
of the delinquencies and
defaults that will come.
So that's a revaluation
of their loan portfolio,
and is likely to continue.
I think I saw Danielle's hand
up as well maybe in there.
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
Yes, and then Adam.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was going
to say one of the other trends
is a change in the pace of
investment into fintech firms.
That's probably
similar to what we're
seeing across the
investing portfolio,
but people are struggling
with finding places
to invest with the
new remote operations,
as well as fintech firms
pivoting and looking more
internally.
And within the
venture capital space,
there's been some reports of
investors advising startups
just to focus more on their
core business operations,
scale back auxiliary functions,
and generally have a return
to core business.
GARY GENSLER: So let's
just take those two.
And we're going to dive all
the way into all of these,
but one is basically that the
funding, the funding coming
in to fintech and the venture
capital firms to themselves,
these two married
points, are really
looking at things differently.
That the companies need to
look at their operations
and look at core operations.
And we'll talk a lot about
that, whether it's in fintech
or more broadly in the
economy, that companies
that were being funded by
the venture capital field
generally are not yet
cash flow positive.
Some are, when they're at
series C or D or even E rounds.
But certainly early
in their lives,
they generally are
cash flow negative.
And so how much
runway they have,
how much time they
have, in essence,
to turn the corner to get cash
flow positive and profitable.
And of course the venture field
itself is being more cautious,
and so funding is slowing now.
You said Adam was also one of--
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Yep, Adam.
AUDIENCE: Hey, good morning.
So my point, not
necessarily related closely
to fintech, but certainly
an important trend
in financial services.
So I'm into commodities,
and I'm working on a paper
with Professor Mirkin
regarding oil prices.
GARY GENSLER: Adam, do you
mind turning on your video
so we're with you?
AUDIENCE: The thing is I
won't be able to see you then.
That's why--
GARY GENSLER: Oh, all
right, so let's keep going.
AUDIENCE: So since you can't
just stop producing oil,
like most of the
valves in the US
and across the globe,
the way it's structured,
it's not a switch
that you can shut off.
And I'm sure all of you know
we don't drive as much now,
and we don't go outside.
Airlines obviously don't operate
with the same capacity they did
before, so we don't use oil.
But on the other end, we still
produce almost the same amount
of oil than before.
Oil prices took a major, major
hit, forcing a lot of valves
to shut down, probably
for good, just
because it's not necessarily
possible to reopen
smaller valves.
And I think the
whole energy sector,
if this goes on for a bit
longer, might be completely--
the way it was
before coronavirus,
it will be completely new after.
Because a lot of
players were forced out.
The US's place as the biggest
oil exporter might change.
GARY GENSLER: So can
we circle that back
to financial services?
What you're saying is
the commodity field,
the commodity sector
is taking quite a hit.
There's a demand shock.
It's been one of the most
serious demand shocks
that we've seen in
several decades,
one might even say
in a hundred years,
on energy and on many
other physical commodities
in the energy and in the metals
space, less so in agriculture.
And so that demand shock
has led to a price shock.
We've also had a bit of
a scuffle between Russia
and Saudi Arabia in terms of
oil production and the like.
And so how does that circle
back to the financial services
field, in your mind, Adam?
Sort of a brief--
AUDIENCE: I follow, as you know
others look into the fields
that they are interested
in, follow a lot of funds,
hedge funds, specialized funds
in energy, commodities space.
And a lot of these
players took major hits.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, so what's your--
AUDIENCE: And some of the
biggest companies in energy
is Zimmer Partners, with
like a 25-year track
preferred of over 20%
average return annually,
so pretty impressive firm.
[INAUDIBLE] reported a 55%
loss in the first quarter.
And they are among the most
renowned funds in the sector.
GARY GENSLER: So
if I can bring it--
Adam, can I just bring it short?
Because we don't
have a lot of time.
Let me just shorten it up.
What you're saying is there's
a commodity price shock.
It's moving into a demand
shock, a price shock,
and it's moving into
financial services
with returns for the
asset managers and hedge
funds in the commodity space.
Did I capture it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, absolutely.
GARY GENSLER: Thank you.
So we've talked a little
bit about how it's also
hitting towards fintech itself.
Some of the funding side, we're
going to go into that more.
But what about the
positive trends?
Are there any positive trends
likely to emerge out of this
for financial technology firms?
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Ivy, would
you like to give it a shot?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So I think there's
definitely going to be
winners and losers from here.
So previously, as
we know, there's
been a huge emergence
in terms of fintech
across all these spaces.
And a lot of them
are not profitable.
And so I think
the positive trend
is that firms with, I think,
disciplined underwriting as
well as actually a
working business model
will emerge from this
unscathed-- not unscathed,
but probably gaining more
market share and doubling down.
So I actually think
that's a positive,
I think, for just
the general market
because it is a
little oversaturated.
GARY GENSLER: So
Ivy's highlighted
it's a highly saturated field.
But for those who have a
truly viable business model,
that may play to
their advantage.
We're also going to talk about
various sectors that might play
to their advantage as well.
And I think there
is another hand up.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Hassan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so, for instance,
I can talk about my
country, Bahrain.
With this pandemic, I've
noticed that people who are not
used to fintech technologies
have not gotten used to it,
and they're taking advantage
of these kind of services.
So I think that even after
this pandemic is over,
behavior has changed forever.
So this is my take on it.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
So it accentuates trends.
We've already been over the
last three-ish, four decades
digitizing the economies, but
not uniformly around the globe.
And so this accentuates
that trend to digitization,
and it accentuates a trend
towards online commerce.
And in both of those trends,
they were happening already.
But I think Hassan's raised
a really important point.
It accelerates some
of those trends.
And those will create
opportunities and challenges,
and there will be winners and
losers, as we talked about.
So I'm going to sort of dive in.
Financial sector
crises are not new.
This is just sort of
a sampling of a list.
And even in 2008, we were
followed by European debt
crisis in 2009 and 2012.
And so the question will be
is not just this crisis, 2020.
Is it to '21?
Is it to 2022?
Does it have
aftershocks beyond that?
I'm here to say it's not
just the 2020 crisis.
But I think you all
knew that already.
But I'm also going to say that
finance, by its very nature,
tends to have crises
every five, 10, 15 years.
And each time, people will
have some conversation
about this is the worst
crisis in 50 or 100 years.
So it seems like we get the
once-in-a-50-year crisis every
5 to 15 years.
And in your careers, you will
probably see five or six more.
Now, God willing, they won't
be driven by a pandemic,
and there won't be millions
of people or hundreds
of millions of people put out
of work through a lockdown
to protect ourselves
against a virus.
But you will see other
financial crises along the way.
I have.
I didn't work in the 1970s,
but from the 1980s on.
And some were more severe
than others, of course.
The financial crisis in
'08-- just to remind you.
We're not going to
dive in deeply--
weak underwriting, a
lot of easy credit,
poor risk management, and
then multiple failures around.
This is what was
called systemic risk.
Emanating first out of the
US and the housing markets,
and the housing markets
had an asset bubble.
But it was also true in Spain.
It was also true in
other European countries.
It was not only
isolated to the US.
But in a financial sense--
not in a health care sense,
but in a financial sense--
we Americans and a couple
other markets like Spain
and elsewhere sort
of propagated out
to other markets a contagion, if
you wish, a financial contagion
to the rest of the world.
Now, some countries like China,
Australia, Canada sort of
weathered the
financial storm well,
but they were still hit
with an economic shock.
You couldn't avoid
it, in a sense,
because we're so interconnected
economically around the globe.
And what was the result after
that crisis, just for a moment?
There was financial reform.
Around the globe, primarily
in Europe, Canada, Australia,
the US, Japan had
to put in place
a stronger set of regulations.
It didn't change the fundamental
basic regulatory environment,
but more capital, more shock
absorbers within the banking
sector, more transparency
in the derivatives
markets, and the like.
TEACHING ASSISTANT: Gary,
I think I recognize you
on this picture, no?
GARY GENSLER: All
right, so where?
Where, Romain?]
TEACHING ASSISTANT:
In the front row?
GARY GENSLER: Oh, you mean
the center, bald head?
No, it's just a
little light hearted.
We could have done a poll
and asked how many people
think that's me?
But I'm sorry to let you down.
That's Ben Bernanke,
the chairman
of the Federal Reserve.
I think I am in the
bottom right-hand corner.
So I think I'm sort of not in
the front row with the chairman
of the Federal Reserve.
I think I was in about the third
row, as my memory serves me.
But thank you.
For those who don't--
I was honored to be chair of
the Commodity Futures Trading
Commission at the time.
That set of reforms--
that set of reforms, I give
you here a four-year-old chart
out of a law firm,
Davis Polk, that
kept track of these things.
But those Dodd-Frank reforms
were around transparency
in the derivatives markets,
asset-backed securitizations,
the sort of resiliency
of banking itself,
and a lot about consumer
protection, mortgage market
reforms, and the like,
and systemic risk.
And so this just
gives you a sense
of all the different
slip streams
that came out of that reform.
Many people would say
that that crisis started
in the financial sector.
It's not quite true.
It was the housing
sector and asset
bubble in the housing
sector, easy credit,
and certainly the financial
sector was at the center of it.
But it's the mix of housing,
finance, and frankly
a failure in Washington
and in London
and elsewhere to stay abreast
and help regulate the market.
So a failure in
the capital markets
and in finance, but also
a failure in public policy
that got behind and loosened
relation to finance.
We're living in a different
set of crises now, I would say.
Fintech, fertile ground.
We've talked about this for
the whole 10 classes we've had.
But in the midst of
the corona crisis,
I think four of the fertile
grounds that we've already
talked about are accentuated.
Digitization of money.
We still have paper money.
I think we're going to
move even faster on this.
What's an interesting thing
in the last seven weeks,
the US Federal
Reserve has actually
continued to issue paper money.
Paper money has grown
not significantly,
but it's grown close to
4% or 5% in outstanding.
Now, that might be
a flight to quality.
It might even be drug
runners who want paper money.
Wide acceptance of new tech.
I think that we already
were realistically
in a mobile phone, mobile
delivery user interface.
But I think that's accentuated.
I think we've
accentuated these trends
about large pools of
data and the value
of those pools of data.
So what do we see in terms
of fintech incumbents
and the big tech?
Well, big finance
we've talked about.
Huge volumes in the capital
markets, government debt
markets.
They're working on these
stimulus loan programs.
And they've also boosted
their allocations
of loan loss reserves.
I think we're still
six to 18 months away
from significant delinquencies.
In the corporate sector and
the leveraged loan marketplace,
we'll see some of those earlier.
The high-yield debt market,
small business loan market,
we'll see those in 2020.
I think in the household
sector, we'll peak in 2021.
I could be wrong.
And when people are listening
to this in the future,
they're going to look back and
say, boy, he took some risks.
But I'm willing to
take some risks where I
think there's some challenges.
I think also big finance is
very reliant on connectivity.
These trading floors-- if
you went into a trading floor
in London or New York,
you would see hundreds
of people on a trading floor.
And now they're dispersed.
And the New York Stock Exchange
went to electronic trading.
Will they ever even come back
with physical market makers
on a floor of a New
York Stock Exchange?
Maybe not.
I'll be willing to
make that prediction.
But big reliance
on connectivity.
Big tech, significant
online growth.
And you have different
parts of big tech.
You have the ones
that are really
focused on data and analytics,
like Google and Baidu.
They're being called
more into the fray
to use that data to help protect
the public through something
called contact
tracing and the like.
You have the online market
shops like Alibaba and Amazon,
huge growth, of course.
So significant online growth.
And then we go to
the fintech startups.
And I'd say the real
focus on the fintech
startups is this number one
point, what's your runway?
A term that we haven't
talked about in this class,
but runway is what's
your burn rate?
See, early startups-- not
just in financial technology--
early startups usually
are spending more
than their revenues.
And they're trying to
work to that sweet spot
when they can get to a place
and be really successful, where,
of course, revenues
are more than costs,
but also they've
built a platform.
They've built and start to
commercialize the network
economics.
And by network economics
or platform economics,
it's bringing two
sides of a marketplace
together and building a
platform in between it.
But there's a big focus on
revenue models and adoption.
And if you've
recently raised money,
you're in better shape
then if you haven't.
So it's not about whether you're
at the seed round or a series C
or D, meaning you've done three
or four rounds of funding.
It's really, how much
cash do you have?
What's your burn rate?
And hunkering down.
IPOs, Initial Public
Offerings, probably
off the table for the rest of
2020, and maybe well into '21.
Venture capitalists will talk,
as you saw in these readings,
that they are
investing, but they're
going to be slow and cautious.
And valuations, just like
the public market's down.
But if you don't
have an IPO takeout,
if you can't exit in
the public markets,
if you can't readily
convince your venture
capitalists about
your revenue models,
your valuations are coming off.
I think consolidation increases.
I think that the sectors
matter, and there's going
to be winners versus losers.
I think anybody that's deeply
reliant on transaction fees,
particularly in the
payment space, that's
a challenge right now.
Some businesses, the
sector matters even more,
like if you were Toast
servicing the restaurant field,
I have not talked to them
since this crisis started,
but I think that's
a challenging thing.
You could be a
transaction-based business
and have been in
great shape in January
and really pretty
lousy shape right now.
So some areas like retail,
travel, events, obviously.
Mobile trading-- mobile trading,
on the other hand, might be up,
the Robinhood numbers
and others like them.
Wealth management
like Betterment
that we talked about, maybe.
But if you're like
Root Insurance,
if you're an auto insurance
tech and people aren't driving,
it might be the other way.
So sector matters a lot.
Compliance up.
International cross-border
remittances, I believe likely
has some possibility.
But I still think runway matters
and consolidation increases.
And so a couple other thoughts.
Additional opportunities.
I think there's
additional opportunities
if you're serving those tapping
into the fiscal stimulus
and loan programs.
So what you've seen
around the globe,
whether it was PayPal,
SoFi, others saying,
we will help a small business.
Revolut in Europe, we will
help a small business fill out
their forms, apply
for the programs
here in the US,
programs in Europe.
And that's an opportunity
to actually build
customer relations.
Numerous amongst the fintech
startups here in the US
have raised their hand and
said to the Small Business
Administration, can
we be basically part
of the PPP program?
I don't mean receive
a forgivable loan.
I mean help issue
forgivable loans.
Romain I want to pause because
I see there is activity
in the chat room and
just see if there's--
TEACHING ASSISTANT: So we have
a general question from Rosanna
on whether there is a chance
that this crisis will impact
the stability of the US dollar.
GARY GENSLER: I
think, great question.
When you say stability,
I think of volatility.
But Rosanna, do you mean that,
or do you mean its centrality
in the world trading system?
AUDIENCE: I think centrality
in the world trade system.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So I think that crises
like this usually--
and history shows
this time and again--
it's flight to quality.
And so right now, the US
dollar is that quality asset.
Our economy has got
huge challenges.
But I'm saying as
a fiat currency
compared to other
fiat currencies,
I think you've still
seen the flight
to quality in the US dollar.
I do think that if you go out
multiple decades, our handling,
as a public policy matter,
people will be looking,
how did our government respond?
How did we respond to
the health care crisis?
And I don't mean in the middle--
right now, there's going
to be all those debates
and they'll influence all sorts
of things like the November
election.
I'm talking about longer term.
Longer term, how
did we as a society,
how did we as a government
handle this crisis?
And I think this story
is not written yet,
even though right now
there's a lot of reasons
to think we didn't handle things
well in January and February
and March.
But we don't know about
the reopening yet.
But the US dollar, which
is probably over half--
depending upon
what statistic you
want to pick, between
half and 2/3 of trade,
the foreign currency markets,
the central bank reserves
around the globe are
on the US dollar.
I think you raise
a great question.
Will it change the US
dollar as the world's sort
of leading currency?
My guess is, probably not.
I think we're still
multiple decades away.
I think if China wants
to take that role
at some point in time, probably
late in the 21st century
sometime, they have to
really adjust themselves
to having a more
open capital market.
The US took the role
from the British
just about the same time
as the last big pandemic,
the one a hundred years
ago, the Spanish flu.
It's a coincidence, maybe,
so you're right to raise it.
But I don't think China
is in the position.
They don't have free and
open capital markets.
The US had free and
They don't, frankly, have the
same legal systems that we had.
And so the UK was in relative
decline to the US already.
I don't think it was the Spanish
flu that gave us the chance
to take over.
World War I did give us
a chance to take over.
And so you're right, some future
crisis might be that moment,
but I don't think
this is that moment.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
What about the
volatility, though?
Do you think also that's--
GARY GENSLER: I've got
three minutes to finish up,
so can we do this offline?
But there's also
additional challenges
on delinquencies and defaults.
I think for fintech
companies, they
have to be very
aware, especially
if you're in consumer or
small business lending,
that delinquencies and
defaults will go up.
I just think-- and if
you have a business
model related to float because
interest rates went down.
So this is where
I'm going to close
is this chart from the Boston
Consulting Group breaks
subsectors.
And again, in this
class, I constantly
am focused on granularity.
You can be strategic, but
you have to be tactical.
You've got to get
down to each sector.
In payments, trade finance
is probably at high risk.
But other areas might be OK.
Account to account,
person to a person
like Venmo, Paypal's Venmo,
might be in a good place.
In lending, unsecured
personal lending,
Boston Consulting
Group says a problem.
But their other parts, like
lending on infrastructure,
might be OK.
So you've got to get granular.
You've got to think about
each sector individually.
Insurance, I also
think it will be
interesting to see what happens
to some of the auto insurers
that BCG hasn't
put on this chart.
Everybody's going to have
their different chart.
This is not to say this
is the accurate chart.
I raised this Boston
Consulting Group
chart because I want to always
remind, it's granularity.
You need both
strategy and tactics
and to get into where the
cracks are in the system.